one of the things that i've really been
struck by lately is
this um
this
this post-modern and radical leftist
insistence that exploitation is wrong
think well why do you think exploitation
is wrong you have to buy the doctrine of
the
inalienable rights of the individual and
the natural rights of the individual and
the divine worth of the individual
before slavery is wrong and you don't
buy any of that but if you do but if you
do buy it you end up like wilbur like
wilberforce and you put yourself on the
line to
what to cost cost england a tremendous
fortune over a multiple decades to
eradicate slavery around the world
because of its moral inappropriateness
because of the sacred nature of each
individual
[Music]
hello everyone
i'm pleased to have with me today dr
michelle mangovati born in
1949 dr mangovadi is founder president
of the book of the millennium
international slash revelation movement
he's an indian philosopher and social
reformer born and raised in india vishal
studied philosophy at the university of
alabad
1967-1969 and indoor 1971-73
in hindu ashrams and at the labrie
fellowship in switzerland in 1976 along
with his wife ruth he founded a
community to serve the rural poor in
india
michelle continued his direct
involvement in community transformation
until 1997 including service at the
headquarters of two national political
parties there he worked toward the
empowerment and liberation of indian
peasants and the lower castes
in 1977 asia's then largest publisher v
cass publishing house published his
first book the world of gurus his next
two books when the new age gets old ivp
1992 and india the grand experiment
hippa ran
1997 brought his work to the attention
of american and european readers
at the turn of the millennium vishal and
his wife ruth were invited to the us to
make a television series exploring the
bible's role
in creating the modern world their
research
prepared in in the process of making a
documentary film has been presented in
text form and on a variety of electronic
and social media platforms
he's lectured in more than 40 countries
and published 17 books
served as the honorary professor of
applied theology in the gospel and plow
faculty of theology the sam higginbotham
institute of agriculture technology and
sciences in el halabad india since 2013.
i recently read two of his newer books
the book that made your world
and
thomas nelson 2011 and in what is some
ways a companion volume and an extension
this book changed everything sought
after press media 2019 it was very
interesting to me to encounter the views
of a non-wester on a non-westerner on
the biblical corpus and its effects on
well
its broad effects on civilization
i was also extremely impressed and happy
to
have had the opportunity to read
books that were so
uh deeply researched and widely ranging
i learned all sorts of things about
western history and certainly a lot
about indian history things i i had no
idea about so ignorant when it comes to
history that it's embarrassing so it was
a pleasure to encounter these books and
to get some sense of the
depth and breadth of scholarship that
went into their production i thought we
could have a pretty interesting
conversation on the
well on the history of india on the role
the bible played in shaping india as a
modern country on your views of the
bible and the west all of that so
welcome to
my discussion
thank you sir
i'm honored
well it's a pleasure to have you here so
um can you maybe start by telling
everyone
how you came across the bible and why
you've made it in some ways i would say
the centerpiece of your life study
yes
while i was studying
philosophy in allahabad university
i
couldn't have any childish faith because
my professors
did not believe
the bible or hindu scriptures
my
i had become a christian as a teenager
because i was going through a moral
struggle i was addicted to shoplifting
and lying
and i hated myself for this habit of
lying when there was nothing to be
gained from lying
and i would meditate and try and control
my tongue
but in the evening when i look back on
the day i have just deceived everybody
that was habit
and
i will try and have more willpower to
control myself
until someone explained to me that your
problem is not real lack of willpower
you're quite stubborn
you have a disease
it's called sin
that rules you
but there's a good news that there is a
savior who can save you from sin
so i asked jesus to deliver me from my
habit of lying but he also went ahead
and delivered me from my habit of
stealing i was able to go back to the
shops from where i had stolen and offer
restitution thankfully nobody took the
money they were all pleased these were
little things that i had how old were
you how old are you
i was about 14
or so i was still a teenager uh
struggling with this model struggle
why do you think why do you think it was
that turning to christianity
actually worked when when your own
attempts hadn't hadn't produced any
positive results
well that is actually
a very good question because
i had already realized that my attempt
to control my tongue
i hadn't heard the word addiction i
didn't know what addiction was
what it meant
so i just
thought that i had these terrible habits
and i knew they were wrong
i didn't know how to get out of them
and so when i was told that there is a
savior who came to save sinners like me
as a child i believed and i asked jesus
uh to forgive my sins and to change me
so the transformation was real i got
very excited you know it's not easy to
go back to the shops and confess that
you had stolen so the transformation was
real but at the university i found that
i couldn't really believe the bible to
be true
uh that was nobody was directly
attacking the bible in the university
but my professors were obviously a lot
more learned than my pastors
and if the professors didn't believe the
bible why should i follow the pastors
so it was easy to doubt the bible
the difficult question was what then do
you believe
and i decided that i'm going to believe
what the best philosophers and
scientists believe
so what do they think is the truth
i began reviewing my course
uh
reviewing all the notes all the books
and i began to realize
that my professors knew that the
philosophers knew that they didn't know
the truth
and that they could not know the truth
so by
philosophy departments in india
already knew
that the enlightenment had failed
nobody in any university believed that i
know the truth and i can teach the truth
so
i began to feel that perhaps the buddha
was right
i come from the same people group as the
buddha
and his parable of the five blind men
trying to make sense of an elephant and
fighting that elephant is like a pillar
like a wall or like a rope
we all have some truth
but that is relative truth relative to
our experience of the elephant
none of us uh really know the truth none
of us really know the elephant so i
thought that perhaps the buddha was
right
and we should be humble enough in
knowing that none of us know the truth
and we should listen to each other
rather than fighting with each other
but that raised the question that if the
five blind men are there who
do not know the elephant could there be
a sixth person who is not blind who sees
the elephant
and who can communicate to me
or what i'm experiencing of the elephant
so obviously
the concept of blindness exists because
there are someone who is not blind
so the sight must exist for the concept
of blindness to exist
so i decided is there someone who knows
the truth has he spoken
this started on my quest a philosophical
quest to
see i first went to
the hindu uh the
gita press guru that sells hindu
scriptures and asked them for a copy of
the vedas the most ancient sacred hindu
scriptures which are supposed to be
revelation
and i was amazed that the
my professors of course had been taught
teaching us the philosophy of the vedas
but they never brought a copy of the
vedas into the classroom
and
i had never seen a copy of the way it
does so
i went to buy one and i was told that
sorry the vedas are not printed they
cannot be translated i was surprised to
learn that actually sanskrit never had a
script
uh because it was oral language so with
sophisticated
grammar
but no script so the vedas were not
supposed to be written down
uh they were to be memorized but and
memorizing was not enough you needed
correct
enunciation and pronunciation and
intonation and when to offer
the melted butter into the fire etc the
rituals that was the purpose so vedas
were never written to know the truth and
in fact the upanishad
which followed the vedas
for example which from which our
national motto comes which is satte mev
jayathi truth alone triumphs uh the uber
shot says
that
no amount of study of the vedas will
ever lead you to truth
because the vedas are not written to
give you knowledge of wisdom of truth
they are magical sounds
uh composed to give you power
so i said well it'll be very nice to
have some power but right now i'm
looking for truth
so i went to
the muslim books because i was in a city
called allahabad
which is a persian name a bird of allah
this city was established by muslims
just two years ago its name was changed
to a hindu name
but at that time it was still seen as a
muslim city and i was surprised that the
quran was not available
neither in my mother tongue which is
india's national language hindi or urdu
which was the language of my town
which is the national language of
pakistan right now so the quran was not
available
the shopkeepers explained to me that you
have to
study um
edible to study quran
so i said well it'll be very nice to
know foreign language but at this moment
i'm not interested in studying a
language if the quran is god's word why
is it not available to me in my language
so it was my older sister who encouraged
me to read the bible and i said to her
that i've already read the bible i think
these are childish stories this is she
said no no you were a child when you
read it
now you think you are a philosopher so
read it as a critical philosopher and as
i began rereading the bible
i found genesis very exciting because it
was answering questions that the
university had not answered about who
who am i what is men yeah well in your
in your book one of the things you do
quite nicely a couple of comments and
what you've said i mean
you make a
a
quite a remarkable
and insightful case i would say
for the particulars of the vision of man
that's embedded in genesis and i found
that interesting it your ideas in some
sense paralleled ideas i was developing
in a course or a lecture series i did in
the bible
that
god contends with chaos to make order
and that man it's and women are made man
and woman are made in the in that image
and there's a
uh um imputed nobility to the human
character that's part and parcel of the
initial genesis story you also make a
case that
and you were beginning to develop that
just now again that um
the universal translation of the bible
has had a revolutionary worldwide effect
on every culture really that it's
touched and that that effect of the book
itself not necessarily the people who
transmitted the book but sometimes them
too
that that effect was fundamentally
positive that it led to uh
an increased appreciation for the
dignity and worth and nobility of of
men and women alike regardless of their
economic status or background
that's absolutely right and we are the
same wavelength at that point
but
later as i kept reading up to say books
like leviticus i found the bible very
poor very boring
book but when i came into the
uh
historical books of kings and chronicles
then i was really fed up
here i am an indian young man i do not
know enough about indian history why am
i reading this jewish book
and as i was ready to close down the
bible once and for all
the
something amazing happened which was
that
uh
indian history
at school level
is always telling us how good great
glorious wonderful our ancestors and our
rulers was this jewish book in kings and
chronicles was telling me how rotten the
jewish kings were
so
i realized of course this is not court
history kings didn't pay historians to
write about their fathers so this must
be religious history of the jews which
is critical of the politicians because
in india
the religious leaders are brahmanas
politicians are chatrias there's always
rivalry between them so i said this must
be a religious book so just to confirm
my opinion of what the bible is i began
rereading these historical books
and i was amazed that the book is
condemning
jewish religious leaders
to the point that god hated them
he destroyed his temple he killed the
priests he sent them into slavery so i
said okay then the bible must be
subaltern history
written from the point of view of simple
jewish people men and women and children
who
are exploited both by religious and
political leaders
but then uh
as i
began rereading these books
i realized no
this book is incredible
it is more anti-semitic than anything
hitler could have written it is saying
that every jew
was an idolater adulterer liar cheater
deceiver etc god hated the people he
destroyed his chosen people send them
into slavery to assyria and babylon
so then i said well this must be the
point of view of the prophets because
prophets love to condemn everybody
uh that's
people would accuse you and me of being
that kind of
voice
so
here i already know that these are very
boring books and within a period of two
months i'm looking through samuel kings
and chronicles for the fifth time to
just confirm my point of view that this
is the word of prophets
but then i was amazed that the book is
saying
most of the prophets were false prophets
the good ones were the losers
they were trying to save their nation
they couldn't save themselves
they were beaten killed thrown into
systems etc
right so you're making the case that
it's not easy to read those books as the
expression of any given dominant group
or power or
or exploitative group or even viewpoint
other than other than what other than an
attempt to lay out some some fundamental
ethical truth well it was a video in
the north of israel a
sidonian widow
who opened my eyes
elijah
is running away from his own king
the king says you are a troubler of
israel
because of you there is three years of
famine
he was hiding in a brook
drinking water from there the bible says
the crows were brief bringing his food
the the brook dried out so he was sent
to this widow of zarephath
and
elijah says please can you bring me some
water and she goes you know he's been on
a long journey he's shouts at a please
also bring me a loaf of bread she says
now that's going too far i have just a
little bit of flour
i'm going to make the last meal
me and my son we eat that after that we
die he says no no you won't die makes
the love for
me
besides yourself and your son she does
so she invites him to stay because she
realizes that she actually had more
flour than she thought
next morning she still has flour and oil
and next evening and the third day and
the fourth day and she begins to feel
this guy is a magician
he is multiplying by a limited flower
and
she's very pleased to have him as the
house guest
but then her son becomes sick and dies
and she's really angry at elijah that
i'm a sinner did you as a man of god
come here to judge me
i have nothing i have no husband i have
no jewelry i have no pots and pans i
have no savings no insurance this boy
was my only hope
and now he is dead
uh because of you so elijah takes him
the boy up
prays for him
the i'd ask god that my whole nation
condemns me as a troubler of israel now
you have brought trouble upon this woman
also
so the boy is resurrected
the woman
when he brings the son back
the woman says
now i know that you are a man of god
and the words of the lord from your
mouth mouth are true
now my professors have no concept of
truth can the words communicate truth
the buddha doesn't believe openshifts
don't believe that human words can
communicate truth but a widow knows
that you are a man of god the word of
the lord from your mouth martha's truth
so i began to look into these old
historical books and i realized that
whatever my interpretation
the book itself is claiming to be god's
word
yeah well one of the things that you do
a nice job of i would say in contrast to
maybe maybe post-modern perspectives in
particular is to make the case that
the
biblical narrative
um is predicated on the idea that there
is a truth that words can aspire to and
words can contain that truth and that
human beings can possess those words
so the
words can refer to something that's real
and absolute and fundamentally true and
we're graced in some sense
by the ability to partake in that
process
and that words have a world engendering
force as well and so
i i thought that defense of of the
biblical perspective was extremely is
extremely what would you say necessary
and welcome in today's world because as
you point out
it isn't
the conclusion of modern philosophers
especially the more radical type that
words refer to anything at all outside
of themselves or that
words can contain anything reasonably
approximating some kind of transcendent
truth
yes that's what i learned studying
wittgenstein
burton russell said that wittgenstein
was the greatest british philosopher of
the first part of the 20th century
and his philosophy of linguistic
analysis he begins with assuming that
the words have something to do with
truth some words can communicate truth
but by the time he's done
he has come to realize uh that words uh
have nothing to do with truth the words
lead to words and more words and do more
words so after that the western
enlightenment philosophy becomes
anti-philosophy it's not a pursuit of
truth uh but it's uh pursuit of um
myth-making uh story uh making um but
so
so you have existentialism etc taking
off from from um
failure of the enlightenment because
that raises the question where does
language come from
so if you take an atheistic position
that we were all primates in the jungles
of sudan and ethiopia and uh
we we were fighting
with each other over mating and food
then the language evolved
because
this is my parable that
a
an eighth
female ape has her
child they're all the whole gang is
resting on the trees so in the morning
she gets up and there is one male
he gets up he's leaving so she asks him
where are you going because they don't
use words and he says that well
yesterday i saw some very pretty females
going towards
ethiopia that's where i'm going she said
you're not going anywhere you stay here
look after my baby i'm hungry my baby is
hungry i'm going to eat find some food
for myself and there are pythons here
they'll eat up my baby unless you sit
and watch over my baby
uh if you don't i'll break your head so
uh in these fights of uh apes or
primates fighting over food mating
rights
the length the sounds animal sounds
become
words language language develops
if that's the origin of language then
the postmodern philosophy is right that
words can have nothing to do with truth
this is where urbanishads and buddhism
had reached that in order to know the
truth you have to empty your mind in
meditation
you have to now they didn't go the way
carl jung and joseph campbell went
because
uh buddha is already critiquing like
socrates he's already critiquing the
myths
that the religious myths that hindus
have created or the greeks have created
these myths are meant not to find
meaning of life and truth these myths
are meant by religious leaders to
exploit the ordinary people
so uh so the buddha has and socrates has
very little use for the myths uh unlike
carl jung and joseph campbell
because they already know
that people are enslaved by myths so a
lot of the new testament is critical of
stories critical of myths although at
the moment the western mind has been
taken over by the idea that we cannot
know the truth but we can invent stories
that know the truth so i i began to
realize that uh if there are five blind
men
there could be a sixth man who is not
blind can he speak
is revelation possible and as i'm
reading the the old testament uh
particularly the boring books of the old
testament i begin to realize that the
book is claiming to be god's word and
there are
umpteen prophecies within kings and
chronicles that are fulfilled during the
lifetime of the that period of the kings
themselves so uh i began to take the
concept of revelation seriously because
also it it also explained the origin of
language much better than the
evolutionists did how language evolved
okay so you
view in in your book um
particularly in
uh let's see in
the book that made your world
you
present a viewpoint that's pretty
positively predisposed to
science and technology and the
enlightenment at least the early periods
of the enlightenment but you see them as
inextricably inextricably inextricably
rooted in a biblical underlay and that
as they became more and more divorced
from that biblical underlay
the more postmodern deviations from the
enlightenment pathway or from the
productive enlightenment pathway
manifested themselves and
you also make the case that while in
india for example which which i found
very interesting that the
the distribution of the bible in
the native languages of the land had a
revolutionary effect and that that
effect was also
manifested in a broad sense in the west
uh against the catholic church and
against well everything that
and against arbitrary political power
political and economic power
that's correct
the
in
scottish enlightenment
there was no atheist in american
enlightenment there were no atheists in
british and the english enlightenment
only thomas hopps was the atheist
it was only when you come to the french
enlightenment that you have atheists
and
the
end result of
french enlightenment was disaster
our universities were telling us the
department of politics etc were telling
us that our freedoms come from russo
world french revolution but they were
also telling us that within three years
of the start of the french revolution
the revolutionaries themselves described
their rule as reign of terror
and within 10 years the whole revolution
ended with the dictatorship of napoleon
bonaparte so
the i began to realize that our
professors were not either they didn't
know the truth that they had been
deceived by american universities
like
ancient philosophy political philosophy
begins with plato republic
plato
the professors are saying that democracy
came from greek city-states
but they are also telling me
that plato says the democracy is the
worst of all political systems he hated
democracy because it was athenian
democracy that killed socrates in order
to defend the myths
so
professors clearly don't know
how we got democracy etc so yes as i
looked at the enlightenment and it was
of course later david grass
his book from plato to nato
that helped me understand why american
universities had deceived themselves and
a whole century of uh
young people
believing that the freedoms came from
greece
the only thing greece ever explored and
from the enlightenment for that matter
but but if the enlightenment's rooted in
biblical ideas i mean
what i another thing i found
particularly interesting about your book
is your insistence and i i believe this
to be the case that
the idea of natural right
is embedded in a biblical conception of
the sovereignty of the individual and
divine worth of the individual
and i i think that case is pretty clear
historically in relationship to the
american declaration of independence but
i also think it's clear and you do a
lovely job of developing this
it's clear that the roots of that idea
were essentially biblical the the the
derived both from the old testament and
from the new testament particularly
genesis and the gospels
that's correct so going back to those
very boring historical books in the
bible uh here is uh
king ahab married to jezebel
nebots his neighbor ordinary peasant has
a very good vineyard
the king wants that vineyard he wants to
pay for it
uh nebbert says no i don't have the
right to sell it because my forefathers
built it up it belongs to my children
and grandchildren the king says i'll
give you double the price 10 times the
market price he says sorry
i i don't want to sell it i can't sell
it this is not mine to sell
no
the king is sulking
jezebel says to him what's wrong
he says well i offered ten times the
market price to this fellow and halfway
i'll turn the vineyard to him he won't
sell it to me so she says
what do you mean are you a king my
father is a king
in sidon uh do you know how to rule i'll
get you the land so she writes a letter
to the village elders to have a feast
bring some scoundrels to make false
allegations false witnesses stone that
fellow she takes the vineyard gives it
to elijah
he gives it to ahab the king
elijah the prophets is furious he goes
to ahab and he confronts him
that you have broken every one of god's
commandments you have coveted your
neighbors vineyard you have lied about
him that he has blasphemed god and king
you have killed him when god says you
shall not kill you may be the king
but there is a law above you which is
god's law you shall not kill
that's the law that gives inalienable
right to life
you have been given the authority to
rule in order to defend the fundamental
inalienable right to life and property
and freedom
but you have violated everything
therefore elijah
judges the king and the queen and his
prophecies turn out to be true that this
is what is going to happen that
jezebel's blood
will be licked by the dots
as
what has happened to nebul's blood so it
is as i'm reading these books i began to
realize that this is the source
of the idea of in india we call it
fundamental rights to like liberty and
of the rule of law yeah under the rule
of law which is right right because the
rule of law is predicated on an id on an
idea
that there's a moral order that's super
ordinate even to the king or the emperor
and that's a transcendent moral order
that doesn't lie in the hands of any
given individual and it is definitely
the case that in those old biblical
texts
the prophetic voice but not always the
winners as you pointed out but the
prophetic voice that carries the main
narrative line continually insists that
if those transcendent ethical rules are
violated even by the rulers who you
would think is it's their prerogative to
set whatever rules they want if there's
no order outside of them even even the
rulers are told by the prophets that
they're support necessarily subordinate
to those rules and that all hell will
break loose if they break them
yeah this of course became very personal
for me
when i started this research and writing
because there had been a hail storm in
1980 which had flattened the wheat crop
in hundred villages
i began to organize release
and the district magistrate sent me an
order formal order that
your work is a legal stop it because
there is a law in our state that in the
event of natural calamity you the no
private parties cannot collect donations
so i gave a formal response and thank
you for telling me about this law we
will obey it
we will not collect any donation we will
give i get a second order that if you're
not collecting any donation how can you
give
so your work is illegal
so
stop it so i wrote formally that the
scriptures uh commanders to obey the
magistrates so we will obey your order
we will not give any relief but we will
ask the peasants who are hurting to pray
for relief maybe the government itself
will grant the relief
i got a third order
that your prayer meeting is illegal now
this was not a christian meeting in a
church this was in gandhi ashram
grantham's style of prayer was very
theistic prayer so gandhi ashram would
be watching us for several years of what
we are doing with the poor they invited
me to hold a public prayer meeting
in their premises and the district
magistrate says this will disturb the
peace and tranquility law and order of
my district so your prayer meeting is
banned now am i now required by the
bible to obey the magistrate or is there
a right
do i have a right to civil disobedience
and as we began to look at this
responsibility or responsibility for
civil disobedience right yes exactly to
be a shepherd do i have to stand up
against the wolves
and uh i was finally thrown into jail
and that's where i began to take a fresh
look at the new testament that jesus is
doing good apostles are doing good
healing preaching teaching about the
kingdom of god why is he crucified why
are they being stoned why are they being
killed why are the trouble makers
turning the world upside down and that's
exactly the point that you made that
the
rulers
government has authority as the
declaration of independence and the
american constitution says that
governments are constituted
to defend and promote the laws
that are given by the creator every
person is made in god's image and
endowed by his creator with inalienable
rights
you give up that biblical framework that
the rights come from god his command you
shall not kill the superintendent of
police highly educated officer he called
me to his home
i sat in his uh living in his lawn in
the easy chair for one and a half hours
he spent an hour telling me that if you
don't cancel that premier i will
personally kill you
i don't need to arrest you i need no
warrant i will not produce you before a
judge i'll come to your home take you
from your home take you into the jungle
shoot you throw your body there the
highness will eat you are you going to
cancel that pregnancy
so uh i said to him of course that i
have to consult my wife if she's okay
being a widow uh and then i'll consider
your request you realize i wasn't taking
him seriously which i wasn't because i
didn't believe that a highly educated uh
gadgeted officer
of the government of india who has taken
an oath to uphold the constitution of
india will have such utter disregard for
my inalienable right to life to pray
uh so
when i was in jail that's when i began
to uh take a fresh look
at why is an apostle paul turning the
roman world upside down
that's what he's accused of
why is jesus being crucified and what
does the cross have to do
with transformation of europe from being
a very intolerant brutal society to a
civilized
tolerant society
yeah well you know i talk to my
audiences across the united states and
say well
it seems
obvious
to me
which doesn't mean it's true that
societies the societies that are
desirable
are free societies and free societies
are predicated on
rule of law
the law independent of the
and transcendent in relationship to the
rulers and
on a conception of man
that gives every individual an intrinsic
dignity that basically has a religious
substructure
and that to the degree that we are
citizens of those lands and we believe
in the principles by which they operate
then we
we're bound to accept that view
because without accepting that view the
whole system makes no sense
like the foundation stone is pulled out
from underneath it and that's a that's
quite the conundrum you know that
there's a biblical vision
underpinning the states that are the
most productive now the radical types
the
leftists in particular say well the
reason that the west is
wealthy and free
is because it was built on the backs of
the poor and
in in in the west and also in the third
world but one of the reasons i found
your book so interesting is that you're
not so fond of that viewpoint
you look at india for example and as far
as i could tell you believe that
the distribution of the biblical
narrative in india has
clearly been a net positive and so maybe
you could outline a little bit of indian
history because i think people would
find that very interesting the british
came in
india was fragmented into hundreds of
cities or states small states ruled over
in many cases by muslims
that was the scene when the british
arrived and the british had their
problems but the but the in
but the introduction of the biblical
narrative into india
in your estimation had a positively
transformative effect much like it had
in in western europe
that's true thank you but you you're
doing wonderful job in
arguing the case that you just outlined
and i hope that many people in the west
and in the east will listen to you
uh because
well we don't believe it anymore that's
the thing but it's also partly because
we're so damn ignorant eh i mean i was
start struck by reading reading your
book how much i didn't know
you know for example this is very
embarrassing to relate i didn't realize
i knew india was fragmented before it
was unified into a modern nation state
but i didn't know it was fragmented and
fundamentally ruled in many cases by the
muslim empire that i just didn't know
that and that's pathetic that i didn't
know that and i also
your book also
helped me understand
see in the west now we tend to think of
the entire christian
tradition
as
oppressive in the catholic sense and i'm
not criticizing the catholics by the way
sure that it was a mono a monopolistic
belief system that was fundamentally
oppressive
now your book helped me understand to
what degree that oppression if it
existed was a remnant of the roman
empire and the empire world view and
that it was the introduction of the
bible and its distribution in all the
vernaculars that actually blew the
remaining empire part of christianity
into fragments and and then in a very
positive way and that's an analogous as
i said to the effect of the christian or
the the biblical
narrative on india which
yep so please please go ahead that's the
indian story that's true
in year 1000 is when
from afghanistan through kyber park or
khyber pass um
the
an invader began to invade india an
attack
so
between 1000 1031
he came about 16 17 times
looting primarily temples religious
temples because that's where the wealth
was
the kings will store the wealth in the
temples
and he would loot the temple
there was a very small a kyber pass only
one place from where
invaders could come from afghanistan
and parashat et cetera
india could have built a small wall of
india we didn't need a great wall of
india to keep the invaders out
but the
indian rulers never built this small
wall
to the point that 100 almost 200 years
later 1191
uh muhammad gauri comes from afghanistan
all the way to delhi almost a thousand
kilometers
and he fights with the hindu king of
delhi he loses goes back 1192 he comes
back defeats prithvi rajan kills him and
delhi is taken over by muslims in 1192.
so
what has weakened and
the hindu kingdoms from
1 000 to 11 90 to almost 200 to 200
years
is a religious ritual called the horse
sacrifice
hindu kings
are sending a horse and behind the horse
are a few hundred young men
they're going into a village either
village becomes their property and
begins to pay tribute to their king or
theirs they have to fight a war so the
at that time delhi's small a bigger
kingdom is
the two hindu kings are
sons of real sisters so their first
cousins
one of the kings uh of cannot chechen
he
starts this ashu media her sacrifice
um
but his brother who is smaller kingdom
but more competent ruler he refuses to
accept the sovereignty of his cousin
so
hatred develops between two cousins who
are governing two important kingdoms in
north india so after in 1192 when the
muslim invader has been defeated by the
king of delhi
the king of kannada
he invites the muslim invader to please
come back
kill my brother
and that's how delhi is taken over by
muslims and then muslims different
dynasties different uh
kinds of muslims rule india until he
ruled delhi until 1858
so how much and how much
to what degree were they ruling over the
rest of what was india as well at during
that period of time it was expanding and
contracting the mughal empire for about
uh 200 years or so
was the most expansive
but
the british had begun to come during the
uh mughal empire uh but
only to trade with permission the french
in the desert and what was the
consequence of the mogul empire well in
relationship to the to the typical
indians life and and to the structure of
the state they built the taj mahal
but they didn't build wheelbarrows
for the laborers who were carrying
bricks and stones
so you build pyramids you build taj
mahal you build palaces this is the
whole middle ages but you don't care for
the wheelbarrows so even today women are
carrying bricks and stones and mud and
cinnamon on their head as they're
building four story halls because you
don't care for the poor so india was
weakened
by what a religious ritual
ashram
which was supposed to make a king very
strong so kings did become strong nation
became weak and divided which allowed
muslim rulers and then french and
british and others to come and take over
so
india for a thousand years almost
um eight nine hundred years was slave
now there were pockets of hindu kingdoms
but some of those hindu kingdoms were
worse
even compared to the muslim ruler like
south india travancore
and these all these rulers hindu and
muslim alike existed in a completely
exploitative relationship in
relationship to their subjects there was
no conception of of individual worth as
you point out there was no conception
that the life of a slave
let alone a female slave let's say or
even a female period for that matter had
any real intrinsic value
that unfortunately is correct let me
give you a very shameful example of what
this means so in south india in what is
now trivandrum travancore
no lower caste woman was allowed to
cover her top
uh if she covered her top she has to
prepare breast tax
which depends on the size of her breast
now even the upper caste women in
travancore this is kerala south india
they
when they go into the temple they have
to remove their upper cloth
because you're honoring the priests you
have to be bare chested
on the street if a
noble
someone from noble family royalty is
passing through on the street the upper
caste women have to take their cloth off
and throw
petals flower petals this is hindu india
while the british are ruling in india so
this these parts of history are
suppressed because they are shameful and
obviously they are shameful that there
is more slavery
in
the hindu kingdom of travancore in south
india than in the muslim
kingdom in the north
so
this is partly because of caste system
so the horse sacrifice was one thing
that had weakened india
past system had weakened india because
if the kings are exploiting my wealth
and putting that wealth in gold
and silver and diamonds in the temples
when an invader comes and attacks that
king why should i sacrifice my life why
should i fight and defend my kingdom
because i have no stake in this kingdom
you are treating me as untouchable and
this is what is happening in india today
every day
that uh the lower past people who are
trying to recover their dignity
that
the hindu religious system has made me
lower than animals
jesus christ is making me a human being
a child of god you won't allow me to
enter your temple jesus is making me a
priest
of the most high god so if they want to
convert
there's persecution happening every day
in india and the supreme
court so now you also made the case that
in the caste system for example that i
thought this was very interesting and
quite damning from a modern perspective
or maybe from a biblical perspective not
so much a modern
that
there was no sense in the hindu caste
structure that the poor and downtrodden
and let's say the untouchables were to
be
revered or served or regarded as
intrinsically noble partly because the
doctrine of karma was predicated on the
assumption
a that they deserved their suffering had
earned it in some cosmic sense and b
that if you did even attempt to
alleviate their suffering all you did
all you were doing cosmically was
prolonging it because the suffering that
they had garnered as a consequence of
karma was deserved and was going to be
played out no matter who interfered with
it and so there wasn't just an absence
of care let's say in some sense for the
downtrodden and the outcast but there
was an insistence that they deserved
their position and that anything that
might be done to help them would
actually be counterproductive now have i
got that right
yes
except i'll take a little further
that is that
inequality self-evident truth
including in america
that men and women are equal was never
self-evident to americans
whites and black slaves are equal was
never self-evident to jefferson's and
washington's and the american founding
fathers
equality is not a self-evident truth
inequality is something yeah quite the
contrary right you could say that that
equality is so non-self-evident that it
would take
divine fiat to make it a reality exactly
so yeah yeah i know that's a powerful
argument and jefferson knew that
therefore in the declaration of
independence he wrote we hold these
truths to be sacred that all men are
created here well it was benjamin
franklin who put pressure on him
and he was trying to please thomas paine
the deist to the rationalists
we can't say that this truth is revealed
to us by sacred writings so right say we
hold these truths to be self-evident
well i think it was it might be fair to
say that those truths are self-evident
in a culture that's absolutely saturated
by protestant biblical presumptions
but they're not self-evident otherwise
yeah they were not self-evident 500
years ago when martin luther discovered
priesthood and kingship of fallen
believers because at that time if a
christian went to the church in germany
average christian only got the bread
symbol of christ's body not the wine the
symbol of blood
the uh blood was only for the priests
so the
the division between priests and laity
resulted in war because if all men are
created equal if every child of god is
supposed to serve god as his priest
manage his kingdom as a king
then uh
this was a revolution a theological
right revolution so yes and it was
resisted that was part of the reason i
suppose that the translation of the
bible was resisted by so many people in
the hierarchical church because people
knew they knew full well that if the
actual words were distributed widely
that that would create a bottom-up
revolution as people realized their
fundamental not only their equality but
more than that
their equality before god and their
fundamental worth and their capability
of having a relationship with truth
and there is maybe no more
revolutionary doctrine than that you
know it hit home for me how
revolutionary the book is and even in
western history
that's absolutely true so uh that
doctrine of human equality
the first thing it does in germany 1524
1525 is the peasants war
uh i'll come back to that but yeah if
before that before luther translates the
bible into german you have wickliffe in
oxford who has translated the bible into
english along with his friends
this is before printing existed before
gutenberg and wasn't waycliffe killed
for his trouble was he was he burned
fortunately not
after he had been putted his bones were
dug out
burns oh yes his bones were burned and
the
ashes were scattered but he didn't die
because part of his time there were two
popes or three
for a while there were three popes
fighting with each other each of them
wanted british support and wickliffe had
become a hero in britain
because
over taxation so the british was so he
escaped that doom but they got tindall i
believe yeah if i remember correctly yes
tyndale was planned
but tyndale is 150 or so years after
white cliff
but so so that's that's even that's
interesting even that that the
resistance to the translation lasted
multiple centuries it wasn't a flash in
the pan it was an extremely dangerous
act to translate the bible into a
vernacular language and you've got to
ask yourself why
you're absolutely right because it was
bishop arundel
the archbishop
of canterbury who
banned wycliffe's bible
and prohibited that no one is allowed to
translate the bible into english without
permission so tyndale spent a whole year
knocking at the doors of three bishops
trying to get permission to translate
the bible into english all three of them
refused so he
became a refugee he
which was also illegal to leave england
without permission he
left england went to wittenberg under
luther began to translate the bible the
new testament then he came to belgium
that's where he printed it to smuggle it
into england so anyone who was found 100
years earlier with a page of wickliffe
bible hand copied
he could be burnt at stake
because
the church has banned translation of the
bible so the bible was an explosive
revolutionary okay
okay so let's let's go back to india
then so now you have the muslim ruling
muslims ruling india and you have the
hindu gods or the hindu kings ruling
india and it's a caste structured
society and there's no shortage of
oppression and there's no real
development at the individual level and
the british start a mercantile
relationship and then the biblical
corpus and enters the indian landscape
through the operation fundamentally of
the british but of missionaries not the
mercantilists per se yes although a fair
number of the christian influenced
british politicians were all already
pushing favorably for india india's
independent development several hundred
years ago way before it actually
happened yes now a few missionaries from
europe had come to south india
before the british missionary movement
got going and they had begun to
translate the bible into some of the
south indian languages etc but this was
small private initiative the missionary
movement per se got started only in 1793
when william cleary a cobbler in england
he was a baptist so he was not allowed
to go into oxford at cambridge these
were anglican universities so he taught
himself on while working as a cobbler
latin greek hebrew
geography politics mission movie history
etc
and he wrote a book a small book
inquiring
whether the contemporary church is under
an obligation to go and evangelize the
world disciple all nations or was that a
command given only for the first
generation of apostles so his book and
enquiry into obligation of the
christians to disciple our nations it's
a very long title that's what begins the
modern dictionary movement
but
ironically
1793 when his book is published is the
year
when the british parliament banned
mysteries from going to india
so
the east india british east india
companies governing bengal which
includes bangladesh assam etc that's a
large part of eastern india
but
missionaries are not allowed
because
evangelical movement is already creating
problem for africa a british rule in
africa because british companies are
bringing african slaves in british ships
selling them in caribbeans and south
america north america
and evangelical conscience which
believes that all human beings are equal
therefore slavery is immoral
they are creating problems and it is the
members of house of lord in england who
have staked in these companies
they don't want missionaries to go we're
having a good time in africa and india
we're making a lot of money we don't
want morality injected into business
uh right but it does get injected
wilberforce manages it unbelievably well
and you know one of the things that i've
really been
struck by lately is
this um
this
this post-modern and radical leftist
insistence that exploitation is wrong
think well why do you think exploitation
is wrong you have to buy the doctrine of
the
inalienable rights of the individual and
the natural rights of the individual and
the divine worth of the individual
before slavery is wrong and you don't
buy any of that
but if you do but if you do buy it you
end up like wilbur like wilberforce and
you put yourself on the line to
what to cost cost england a tremendous
fortune over a multiple decades to
eradicate slavery around the world
because of its moral inappropriateness
because of the sacred nature of each
individual
that's absolutely right that if a woman
is an animal and i can buy a cow keep a
cow in lock and chain
and sell a cow why can't i buy girls
keep them locked and sell them
is a girl different than an animal
does she have yeah and if power is the
if if power is the only force that is
real
and the only force that's credible then
obviously you can buy and sell if you
have the power to do it
you can only not do that in some
fundamental sense if there's a
transcendent order let's say that that
interviews each individual with
fundamental worth the inalienable right
to liberty
that a woman cannot be kept in cage
because she is
made in god's image who is free yeah so
this well i've been thinking i'd be
thinking about that practically too you
know so
think imagine it this way so
the reason that you have the right to
liberty is so that you let's say you
have the right to conscience and you
have the right to conscience so that you
can make appropriate ethical decisions
and states depend on ethical individuals
to make appropriate ethical decisions to
keep the states from crumbling which is
basically the stories that go throughout
the old testament is that when all the
individuals who make up a state become
enslaved or become so corrupt that they
no longer make appropriate decisions the
entire state is doomed and everybody
collapses into slavery
and so you have
you have your freedom you have your
liberty not so that you can do whatever
you want but so that you can exercise
your conscience in relationship to your
well let's say divine calling
that's absolutely right the idea of
functions is foundational to whole of
western political philosophy
that the reality is that in human body
there is no organ called conscience
conscience is an aspect of human
soul the spiritual dimension of a human
being where my conscience judges me that
you're lying that you're shoplifting
you're a thief you're a liar you're a
sinner
so conscience is
um
the image of god in me which can be
corrupted but can be reformed
so
this this is of course the fundamental
source of
liberty when uh
15 21 22 uh martin luther is standing in
the diet of once the emperor has called
for luther to be tried because
the roman empire cannot be divided when
the turks are attacking it he wants
unity so he wants luther to explain
himself and he says okay these are your
books yes sir and these are the books of
the church fathers yes sir
your books contradict the books that the
church fathers have written for a long
time yes sir they do
so will you repent
he's not given an opportunity to defend
himself because you are contradicting
what the church fathers have said
you should recant
otherwise you are a heretic
that means that any christian can kill
you and will go to heaven
so luther takes 24 hours and that
happened just uh two three weeks ago the
500th anniversary of the diet of worms
when luther spends a whole night in
prayer
that do i can't save my life
or do i
remain true to my conscience so he makes
that classic statement
uh that
i
it's not safe it's not right to go
against one's conscience
i will repent i'm not being proud or not
again i will repent if you convince me
from scriptures and plain reason
if not i'm sorry i can't repent so help
me god that's right here i stand here i
stand so help me god no
that doctrine of conscience
comes from paul uses the word repeatedly
in
his epistles such as timothy and titus
that this is the true religion not all
the rituals not all the sacraments but
to keep your heart
clean pure right it's the prophetic
voice within essentially yes
so
that then is debated and um
milton john milton the puritan poet uses
it in his argument for arya pagitika
inaudible and he argues for liberty to
even if i'm wrong i should have the
freedom to express my false ideas
you should counter my false ideas with
um
uh
arguments and evidence not by the sword
this yeah that's part of the refinement
of conscience you could say that
so then at that time during oliver
cromwell's
ring
long parliament appoints westminster
assembly assembly of 70 or so
theologians
who write westminster confession uh
chapter 20 is the chapter on conscience
it was so the parliament accepts
westminster confession as the summary of
biblical christianity
and it was true that the conscience
enters the
doctor the political philosophy of the
west
that the the root of it goes back to
lecture sermon
and how does that how does that parallel
wilbur wilberforce's emergence as an
anti-slavery campaigner he he comes to
300 years later uh yeah but the the
background of it is martin luther's
sermon
which john locke quotes in his letter
concerning toleration which uh
medicine james madison when introducing
bill of rights in america he quotes
martin luther's sermon it's called on
two kingdoms that there are two kingdoms
kingdom of christ which has come into
this world and the kingdom of man
the emperor and the church the pope
have authority over me in some areas but
the church doesn't own my soul
emperor doesn't own my soul if i have
accepted jesus as my lord
it's god's kingdom has come into my
heart christ is my lord
he is the king of kings he's the ruler
of the kings of the earth
therefore my heart belongs to jesus
and the government has no business
in interfering with my conscience with
mine okay so now now these ideas come
into india and you talked about the
missionary distribution in the
vernacular and one of the things you do
quite nicely i thought in in in the book
that made your world
is detail out the effects
on the language and the culture of the
society's in which to which the bible
was uh what would you say
where the
to the languages in the societies that
were provided with or offered a
translation of the bible because it
meant a codification of the language and
often the transformation of what was
only a spoken language into a written
language
to the demarcation of the language as a
consequence
to the possibility of a written
civilization and then also to the
possibility of that
society now developing its own
literature
literary vernacular as an offshoot of
the
of the biblical corpus
very interesting development of the word
a as a consequence of the translation
efforts because they often get pilloried
in the west right because the
missionaries are seen as part of this
oppressive western colonial
movement that that the radical types who
criticize it don't differentiate right
they just assume it's a uni a unipolar
oppressive mechanism that's that's
orchestrated from the top down and
purely exploitive
absolutely so wilberforce is a central
figure in this
three things flow out of his 20-year
battle on behalf of india
one is
permitting
missionaries to go as educators because
all the education was department of the
church it didn't become a department of
the state
until much later
so at that time every teacher is a
reference you know university teachers
etc bishop is the chancellor of the
universities
so uh builder force is uh he fought for
20 years that it's not enough to
send only soldiers and
traders to india
we must god could not have
their belief in providence that history
is not uh a mindless
uh
series of accidents that there is god or
a repetitive cycle yes
there is providence guiding history god
called abraham isaac and jacob you
follow me i will bless you i will bless
all the nations through you so blessing
india was part of god's plan
he could not possibly have given india
two britishes in their company to be
exploited but to be blessed
therefore we must send missionaries to
educate india so that they can govern
themselves
so the it takes 20 years he loses okay
so let we should let's let's let's not
gloss over that too quickly so what we
have here is in the midst of um
structure that could have turned into a
permanent empire we have a movement
within
that empire itself that draws on its own
conscience to reveal to itself that
any continued history of exploitation
regardless of how profitable is immoral
now that happens with the slave trade
and it happens in the case of well much
of the british empire but particularly
in india so they're working against
their own financial um interests in in
many in many ways it's certainly the
case with the war against the slave
trade
absolutely and so that's very weird
right we want to remark on just how
strange that is that's unheard of well
let me
illustrate that africa point first
british ships are going to africa
britain is industrial country it is
producing a lot of things is taking them
selling them in africa africa is not
producing anything at that point so the
ships have to go empty to the caribbeans
or the america
there's a limit to how many monkeys and
zebras you can take
so they begin to take slaves which are
needed in the caribbeans in the
tea plantations and other plantations
so you take the slaves and then they're
making sugar
and you're bringing sugar back to europe
so this triangle of trade
if the ships are going empty from africa
to the to the americas then the shipping
business in
slavery and slavery can get a slavery
can get a toehold because it's way
outside on the fringes of the
of commercial activity and invisible at
least to begin with in some sense and if
your ships are not allowed to take
slaves the spanish will the portuguese
will so you might as well so
when wilbur force is fighting against
slave trade
he is hurting
the
briton's economic interest and everybody
knows that and that's why it takes a
whole lifetime i've read calculations
that the british spent more fighting the
slave trade than they gained
economically from supporting slavery to
begin with by quite a large margin
i don't know if that's true you know but
no that's true that's
that's what adam smith had already
argued in uh his book the
uh
wealth of the nations was published 1776
the same year as american independence
and he argues that free
worker is much more productive and
profitable than a slave so right so that
was true except that that was an
academic theory uh in reality the
shipping company
needs to take some something from africa
to america's uh to make the navigation
work so uh in the end whether the slaves
are more productive or uh harmful right
right right isn't it is an economic
debate
but so
this is why wilberforce is a
troublemaker
he never goes to india but he's
important for abolition of sati widow
burning as well
but he has two
main assistants
zachary mccauley is his right hand man
again against his fight against slavery
charles grant is wilberforce's
right-hand man the charles brown
actually becomes a member of parliament
and becomes the director of east india
company his will before his right-hand
man again about how to reform india
beginning with how to reform the british
misrule in india because he has
personally seen
that east india company in governing
india is a gang of public robbers
lord mccauley the son of zachary mcauley
he's the one who called east india
companies rule for the first 50 years as
a gang of public robbers rule of an evil
genie because the soldiers and traders
who had come to india they were
basically riff raff of british society
like the conquistadors in yes
in the new world correct
so they were looting
did god give india to us
so that we might loot india this was the
conscience troubling charles brown
and he wrote the book in 1793
at the request of wilberforce
it was not published in 93 it was hand
copied they had copies in those days
this was for the
members of parliament because the
charter of east india company they had
the monopoly so the charter had to be
renewed every 20 years and in
this was written to influence the
renewal of the charter and to insert a
missionary clause so from 1793
onwards grant begins to play a very
important role although bilbao forces
the face the political face of that
movement
so they a fight for
um education
and the parliament finally in 18 yeah
they granted a hundred thousand is that
that was they granted a hundred thousand
pounds or they forced the the
distribution of a hundred thousand
pounds a hundred thousand rupees which
was
sorry rupees yeah equal of the pound
more or less that
from its profit
east india company must spend hundred
thousand rupees for public education
so that we begin to train indians to
govern india
now this right again a revolutionary an
unbelievably revolutionary concept it's
it's unprecedented it's an anti-empire
in the extreme
and
lord macaulay who argued and finally won
the debate in parliament in 1833 he says
exactly what you're saying
that uh
this has never happened
but this would be our greatest glory
not that we are ruling over illiterate
people
but that we found people
living in darkness incapable of
governing themselves
and we so ruled over them that they
became capable of ruling themselves okay
now so let's take that apart a bit
because you know the the radical types
again are going to insist that
england or that britain imposed english
as a language on on india and that that
the fundamental again the fundamental
orientation was exploitative but one of
the things that you point out quite
clearly is that the missionary types in
particular driven by their biblical
presuppositions did everything they
could to translate the bible itself into
the local vernaculars into every
language that anybody else spoke and
that's part of that general missionary
evangelizing proclivity i went to the
museum of the bible in washington they
have a really it's a great museum by the
way
um they have a very interesting room
there that contains
virtually every
one copy of
a bible
translated into almost all the languages
that the bible has been translated into
and there's a variety of empty shelves
although a small proportion
that are devoted to
the next decades i think they figured
the bible will be translated into
virtually every living language within
40 years from now something like that
and so
those biblical translators had
tremendous respect for the local
vernaculars they translate they
transformed them into written languages
which was no small feat and they enabled
all of those people to start to learn to
read and to think for themselves that's
that's how it looks
right so and it's likewise the case that
in europe the monasteries were the the
central focus of what became partly
industrial production and also
institutes of higher education so this
idea that the the biblical
world was
was opposed to
education and to enlightenment in
general that's fault that's just false
it's backwards
absolutely true
um
everyone agreed
whether
christians or non-christians politicians
everyone agreed that if india had to be
reformed vernaculars had to be developed
because that is what happened in europe
latin was the language of learning
language of course
but with the reformation german and
french and english and spanish and
portuguese every language began to be
developed and
so
because that's what the principle of
human equality meant
that
every child should be able to study
in his own mother tongue in his own
heart language right well every every
soul had to be reached yes
but also
not just reach to be taken to heaven but
reach to become king because the lamb of
god shed his blood
so that
slaves of satan
are transformed into sons of god
serving their father
managing his affairs
doing his his will in their life and
making sure that god's will is being
done on earth so everyone becomes a king
and therefore the
truth of god what is god's will i can't
do god's will if i don't know god if i
don't know his will so everyone has to
be educated in his own mother tongue
this is what begins
this is the thrust of the entire
missionary enterprise british and
non-british in india
but the question is what exactly will
develop indian vernaculars
no pundits
no imam had any interest in any of
indian languages at that time
india had three classical languages
sanskrit was the language of brahmanas
but only of males
arabic was the language of the mosque
of imams and the only and the only
language that the quran could be
distributed in at that time
and persian
so mughal empire
humayun had made persian
the official court language of india
in order to keep the non-persian
speaking muslims away from the throne
so the persian was a sophisticated
language but in india it was used as a
language of discrimination
just as sanskrit was used as a language
of discrimination against women against
lower cost so no hindu muslim scholar
had any interest in any of indian
languages
the current national language hindi
didn't exist
urdu didn't exist there were dialects
that these missionaries
began to transform first was hindustani
well right that we should concentrate on
that too because people don't really
understand this you know when i went to
switzerland in 1982
there were still places in the backwoods
in switzerland where the people at the
top of the mountain spoke a language so
different from the people at the bottom
that they couldn't understand each other
and so the rule of thumb for languages
isn't
well the language is basically
comprehensible
by everyone but there are various
accents the rule is that there's an
unbelievable multitude of dialects
such that people in one village can't
understand the people in the next
village and so then the european
missionaries come in and start to codify
and unite these languages and also to
give them their written expression
first of all developing an alphabet
often
correct
so um
this
the the question that really occupied
was that once you have these hundred
thousand rupees
how is that money going to be used
and there were processes who were saying
that we should use this money to teach
sanskrit arabic and persian so there was
already sanskrit college in banaras
funded by east india company and
calcutta madrasa teaching arabic funded
by east india company but others began
to say that look
if somebody masters all the sanskrit
literature all the arabic literature he
or she is not going to be give the uh
able to give to in vernacular knowledge
of science knowledge of economics
knowledge of technology of law right
these these productive these productive
fields which you also whose development
you also traced in large part to the
monastic tradition yes so that's why it
was the anglicist
argued that we can't educate everybody
with the limited money that i have
we have therefore
let's
teach english so there will be a group
of indians small group of indians who
are able to read english literature
and take the knowledge from england give
it into bengali give it into gujarati
and hindi so
lang english language was brought to
india to empower indian
vernaculars now we have many high-past
hindus did you suppose that there's a
single university in the west that
actually teaches that fact
well a friend of mine took these ideas
which you have read and
wrote a phd thesis
which was submitted to the university of
nagpur five brahmans were appointed to
study his thesis before giving him a phd
they took five years to investigate his
thesis because he was showing that every
single modern indian vernacular language
is creation of bible translators after
five years
they gave him a phd and they wrote in
their recommendation later that when his
book is published it should be a
required reading in all the department
of linguistics
that every single modern indian language
is a creation of bible translators
uh and yes that's uh that's absolutely
unbelievable and and you
i i just can't imagine that being
accepted without a tremendous amount of
resistance
anywhere that idea anywhere in the west
his book is called let there be india
it's a big book the shorter version is
still in print the bigger version we
have to reprint um but you're absolutely
right that right now there are about 100
dialects in india which are being
transformed into literary languages
right missionaries who are risking them
these are indian missionaries who are
going into remote areas tribal areas
hill hills uh sacrificing everything in
order to
transform these people because
a civilization can only grow as far as
their language will take them
a stone age tribe
doesn't have you can't teach science to
them you can't teach a
business law to them
because their dialect doesn't have the
vocabulary the grammar the structure to
make these books available so a bible
translation what do you think what do
you think of arguments that might point
out that that the counter argument might
be
well why should we
um
assume
that the benefits of say western
civilization or biblical civilization
for that matter should be imposed on
these people
why can't we let them just pursue their
own development why should we assume
that there's anything superior about uh
biblical civilization in relationship to
stone age life
yes
that's a valid question
my wife and i wrote a book on william
carey
the father of modern india
who was the main figure behind this
bible translation and publications for
the first 40 years
of the
modern india now he was also the man who
fought against widow burning his yes if
he was important
you also have an interesting story in
your book about a girl that was starved
to death by her parents actually
yes but i i actually
i also began a fight against revival of
video burning in uh 1987. it 18 year old
widow was burnt alive that's when i
began to discover these uh builders of
modern english right as part of an
equally valid alternate cultural
tradition yes but the point i was making
was
that
a lady
speaking in harvard university
was showed our book on william carey to
her audience and she said that here is a
gentleman
a cobblerton linguist the father of
modern india
who helped abolish widow burning
and an american caucasian white woman
doing phd in harvard
she got mad at the speaker
what right did this white english man
have
to say that burning videos alive is bad
well that's a good that's exactly the
question we asked earlier about slavery
if you don't buy the doctrine that women
have
ins have what
permanent and
and uh
divinely valuable souls
and and the kind of kingship in
principle that you describe
then there's nothing stopping you from
doing that except
the arbitrary
facts of chance in
society
you have to have a view of of the
individual as made in the image of god
and equal before the law yeah in
consequence
before you can say that that's
self-evidently wrong that's how it looks
to me exactly so here is harvard
university
teaching a phd scholar that all cultures
are equally valid if a culture
burns the widow alive
that's valid should be respected and
what if they gas the jews how's that
prevalent or what if they kill six
million ukrainians not okay too
about the jews
they have very strong presence in
hollywood so uh harvard would be afraid
of taking on hollywood
because there are some boundaries
arbitrary boundaries but the the jews
right but but it isn't much of it isn't
much of a leap from widow burning to to
to the holocaust furnaces it's just a
matter of scale
exactly so when we first hand discovered
infanticide in india
you just alluded to it this little girl
sheila 18 month old
being starved to death by yeah tell that
story tell that story that's a very
interesting story
well i was
we had ruth and i had my wife ruth and i
had just moved into
a village in the middle of nowhere
in chattarpur district madhya pradesh
and i was writing my first book the
world of gurus which was later than
published by the
biggest publisher in asia because and it
became a textbook in many universities
including cambridge so in
study of contemporary hinduism was using
my book so that's what makes me an
indian philosopher
who studied hindus and written a book so
i was writing we had no table and chair
we had
put a
small wood into the wall and i was
sitting on a stool and writing my wife
sat on the other side of the bed my
english was very poor but she had had
english education she she was editing
and typing
my manuscript
when i didn't have enough work for her
she would pick on her bicycle and go
into the village door to door to find
out how many kids were there how many
were going to school
what can we do for those who were not
studying etc so she ran into a 10 year
old girl lulta and asked her how many
brothers and sisters do you have lilta
said three maybe four
so ruth was curious do you have four or
do you have three she said well three
fourth is almost dead can i come and see
the fourth so lolka took
ruth in the middle of this is one
bedroom hut with patched roof
no light light is sunlight is just
coming through the roof
and here's this 18 month old girl in the
middle of the room
on a string cart
with no mattress or anything under it
unable to cry
flies all over her because bus is oozing
out of everywhere including her head
ruth began to cry
what's wrong with her the mother's smug
oh she doesn't eat anything whatever we
give her she woman's so have you taken
her to the hospital how can we take her
to the hospital we don't have any money
really i'll give you the money you take
her to the hospital no no i can't go to
the hospital i can manage the city well
take your husband
my husband
who will look after the cows the field
ruth said really
i'll give you the money to hire a
laborer
to look after you feel for one day you
go with your husband okay i'll also come
with you
she said to get rid of ruth she said
okay i'll talk to my husband when he
comes in the evening so ruth came back
started urging me that you go and talk
to the husband i've done my job i went
back they decided they are not going to
the hospital why we don't have any money
but my wife told you she'll give the
money oh we don't want to get into debt
no this is not a debt this is a gift
i'll write give it in writing
but we don't have the time
well
my wife told you that she'll pay for a
labor
then they got angry at me why are you
bothered
and i couldn't understand that's a good
question that's a good question i i
couldn't understand
the only rational explanation as far as
i'm concerned was that they really
wanted to kill the baby
is that possible i didn't believe that
but
i decided to use that
to mobilize public opinion
that are you killing this girl why are
you so heartless why don't you take a
knife stab her why are you prolonging
her misery
they were about more angry at me i found
no support in the village
because i didn't know at that time that
female infanticide was a common practice
everybody did it if you had a second or
third daughter
so
um
i decided to
i pretended that i'm angry i raised my
voice that look if you don't take this
child to the hospital tomorrow i'm
bringing the police here that you are
murdering this baby
so one elderly man said to them that
look uh you better listen to this guy
he's crazy he might actually bring the
police and in that case
you will have to pay for the hospital
expense right now they are offering to
pay take it so
the girl went a long story which i
discussed in the chapter uh twice the
process was repeated she spent two three
weeks in the hospital came to our home
recovered the mother will come and fight
and ruth would say of course we want you
to bring up your child we will pay for
the milk you raise your daughter
but
uh the second time within two days the
child was dead
i was convinced that the parents had
killed her ruth didn't believe that it
was possible for a parent to kill their
child
until we saw three four other kids being
killed
by their parents because
one woman came she saw all of this
struggle she had just had twins she
wanted us to take the weaker and the
darker kid and we had just had our own
baby and ruth said no i'll give you the
money i can't take responsibility for a
second child and
next day the child was dead so we saw
instances like that uh and then we
realized
that
it is not self-evident to these people
that every child has an inalienable
right to life
that's our world view
and it's not just they're not bad people
they're doing what everybody else does a
second daughter is a liability
uh one daughter is enough to look after
the siblings to
clean yeah well what one whether they're
bad or not is not the issue
in some real fundamental sense the issue
is whether or not that is bad you know
in its multi-dimensional reality and you
can be a relativist and you can say well
you know those are the breaks given the
socio-economic conditions but then you
have to say well then it's okay for
people to kill their daughters it's like
well maybe that's not okay
like seriously and that's a that's a
strange case because you have to come
down on one side of the other either
it's okay or it isn't those are the only
options so so imagine there is no law
that you shall not kill your child
then it is culture
everybody does it
why shouldn't i
does the culture decide
whether killing an unwanted girl is
right or wrong
well the nuremberg decision was that the
culture doesn't get to decide
so
right fundamentally that was the
nuremberg decision but the americans had
the dominant power at that time to
overrule the fascist argument the
fascists right run but but the thing is
if you dispense with it you have to
dispense with the nuremberg judgment
and then what the what the germans did
in world war ii was just a matter of
culture like these these ideas they have
some pretty i know you know this i'm not
telling you this obviously you know it
but
lots of people don't know it okay so
we're gonna run out of time and i'm i
don't want that but i would like to so
i'd like to close this properly and i
would like in all likelihood to talk to
you again especially about your newer
projects your work on islam for example
i think that would be a great discussion
but let's go back to the effect
the effect of the biblical revolution in
india maybe you could just flesh that
out for people and and
i know that's a terribly complicated
thing to do no no we can do the simple
things from where we began so
this money is available
dialects are being turned into languages
so that every child has an opportunity
to study
which
it had never happened that the son of a
shepherd
will learn to read write do mathematics
son of a fisherman carpenter this has
never happened so
uh the nation begins to rise up
mughal are ruling delhi for 250 years
they haven't built one hospital
for women in delhi
the first hospital in delhi is saint
stephen's hospital
which was born because of his 16 year
old english girl priscilla
she comes because her brother had been
killed in a 7
revolt
she comes to bless
those who have killed her brother
and she sits by the river king yamuna in
uh the reaganjian
delhi and with his chest
of medicines begin to give free
medicines to women who have no one so
here you have the mughal empire for 250
years in delhi has not built one
hospital for women in india for their
own women in delhi
when a 16 year old girl comes and
because jesus said said go and preach
the kingdom of god and heal the sick
so that compassion
which the the upper caste indians just
cannot understand because they don't
have that compassion they are using
medicine
to make money
there are exceptions but by and large
the the
medicine has become a greed driven
business
it's not a ministry of compassion uh
which it used to be uh so agriculture
indian agriculture is transformed
william kerry himself
in 1820 he establishes the first
agri-horticultural society in calcutta
no such society exists anywhere he's not
copying anything from england
he's realizing because charles grant has
written in 1793 the pathetic state of
agriculture in india so beginning with
william carey
the all the builders of dams and
irrigation canals uh
sam higginbotham
i was professor in sam higginbotham
university it was an institute when the
book was published now it's a university
assam higginbotham university of
agriculture technology and sciences
finally
uh
northern burlock the father of green
revolution during revolution
the entire transformation of indian
agriculture
is a fruit of the bible
because this is what isaiah has
prophesied
that
in the last days the mountain of the
lord will be lifted up
nations will flock to steady god's law
they will beat their swords into
plowshares their spears into pruning
hooks the instruments of agriculture and
horticulture
because the bible sees
the curse upon the ground that ground
will grow thorns and thistles
you will have to eat of the sweat of
your brow
the sin is not something that just takes
your soul to hell
still results in curse upon the land
agricultural production and yeah and
destructive toil which you said right
within and one of the things you pointed
out was that although
there was tremendous respect
so there's the sin-like aspect of toil
but there's tremendous respect in the
biblical corpus for the idea of
productive work as opposed to pointless
toil
and the multiplication of work for the
ennoblement of people yes i have that
very
important chapter on the rise of
technology
when you refer to the
the wealth of europe came from a
colonial exploitation that nonsense
which is talked about the countries such
as switzerland which never colonized
anyone finland uh which never colonized
anyone it was itself a colony of sweden
for several hundred years and then for
russia of several hundred years these
nations have blossomed because of the
intellectual and transformation
including uh
the work work ethic etc right so this is
what the bible brings to india
although as the universities have
removed the bible indians don't know
uh their own history
it's very yeah well welcome to the club
yeah it's very embarrassing for a hindu
historian to admit
that it is a simple 16 year old girl who
is just obeying price in compassion that
leads to the foundation of the first
important
first hospital in delhi etc uh but the
entire transformation of agriculture
medicine education
the transformation of languages that we
have talked about
um
and then and then eventually the
political transformation and the
emancipation of india free press
law legal system
that we have 400 worth 4 thousand years
of history and prehistory not a single
civilization has given us a concept of
rule of law
equality before law justice for all
the creation of civil services
the which is called the steel frame of
in of india it was sons of the pastors
of poor pastors in england
they sent their sons to india to build
the indian civil services in the police
force right well that's part of it and
that's part of that strange notion too
that that's biblical i think in its
essence that
to lead is in the truest sense to serve
and yes to lead is in the truest sense
to serve those who need to be served
most and that that's the highest
possible ethical calling which is a very
strange that's certainly not a brahmana
doctrine
no the doctrine there the doctrine in
any society that has an explicit or
implicit caste system and that's pretty
much any society i would say
that's virtually any society perhaps
that doesn't have a biblical orientation
is that
why in the world would you serve
subordinates that's that's that's
completely beyond comprehension all that
does is demean you
yes
it's a transformation of leadership our
first prime minister used to say that
i'm prime minister which means that i'm
the first servant
prime minister minister is a servant
now i heard him when i was only 13 years
old and i knew that he is saying that
modern india
had a political revolution
where kings began to lose their power
servants began to increase their power
the first servant became the most
important office
so
this revolution began uh the night
before good friday when the king of
kings the lord of lords got up from the
dining table
put on the robe of the servant took a
basin of water started washing the feet
of his disciples
and he said that the new kingdom that i
have brought
is different from the kingdoms of this
world they're rulers lord it over them
but amongst you whoever wants to be the
greatest will become the servant
so this political revolution came into
india but we are losing it political
office now means the right to root
uh education now means a university
degree
is a license to look
that's why our nations are as corrupt as
they are because the the all the senior
officers
bankers
police officers they're highly educated
people
but
university degree simply means the
license to root
if
the education is not a transformation of
character
of making you servant that you're being
given this privilege to serve your
people be a good neighbor
right look
i think that's a good place to stop
you know that's a nice ending
obviously
there we could talk for hours and i
would like to talk to you again as i
said particularly about your new work
but uh i appreciate this very much i
just reiterate for those who are
listening um
the book i would say that
that is perhaps central to the
discussion we had today is called is
entitled the book that made your world
it was published by thomas nelson in
2011 and so it's a tour de force i would
say conceptually and historically
uh
um
conceptually because
it brings to light in in a very
interesting way and in the non-western
way which is also extremely interesting
the truly revolutionary nature of the
distribution of the biblical writings
it's it's hard to overstate their
revolutionary significance and then
um in terms of breadth and depth well
there's a wealth of historical
information that is encapsulated in the
book and it's written in a lovely style
it was very straightforward read despite
its dense layering of information and so
um i much appreciated it
and uh appreciate your conversation with
me today and i hope everybody who's
listening found it
thought provoking and useful and and uh
valuable so let's speak again sure
you better you bet yeah really good to
talk to you and and uh thanks for your
books a lot
thank you for what you're doing